i think what today's figures show is
that in spite of global inflationary
challenges the uk economy remains
resilient
the economy's bigger than it was before
coronavirus and over the last few months
we've grown faster than america germany
france and italy for example but i know
these are anxious times and
unfortunately because the challenges we
face are global in nature i i can't just
make them all disappear but where we can
where we can make a difference where we
can make a difference of course we are
and that's why we're investing billions
of pounds already to support families
and businesses through some of the
challenging times ahead you know very
well that a lot of this is about cost of
living and inflation people simply can't
afford to spend their money in the
economy at the moment honestly with your
hand on your heart talking directly to
people at home who are making desperate
decisions about how often to feed their
children can you honestly say to them
that you believe you're doing enough
as i have over the last two years i've
always acted to do what i think is right
for the country and to support our
country and families and businesses but
what are the difficult times ahead now
we've done a lot already whether it's
support with people's energy bills
cutting fuel duties very significant tax
cut that's coming in in just weeks time
on national insurance thresholds but
i've always said i stand ready to do
more as we learn more about the
situation and and ex on energy prices in
particular the price cap protects people
for some months to come but i've said
when we when we have a clearer picture
about what happens with energy bills we
stand ready and i stand ready to support
people a lot of people will say standing
ready is not enough people are going
hungry right now and lots of these
things take time to implement what are
you waiting for well that's why we've
already announced things in advance of
this energy price cap increasing and
that was in february i say this just
scratches the surface
nine billion pounds and for a typical
family it's a 350 pounds worth of
support compared to a bill increase of
about 700 pounds on average so i
wouldn't say it's just scratching the
sides that's that's half of the total
increase 150 pounds of that has already
been distributed to the vast majority of
families through a council tax rebate
there's 200 pounds further to come but
that's not all we're doing fuel duties
already been cut that's worth about 100
pounds a year together with the freeze
and in just weeks time it's really
important for people to to remember
national insurance thresholds will be
raised which means the first 12 and a
half thousand pounds that someone earns
will they won't pay a penny we've had a
lot of that back in the
that's worth 330 pounds a year that's a
significant amount of help for people i
want to talk about tax cuts the prime
minister's made it quite clear he would
like to see tax cuts uh will we see them
before august well we've already started
seeing taxes but are we going to see
more over and above what you've
announced well you wouldn't expect me to
comment on future tax policy but again
what we started in autumn last year we
cut the tax rate in our welfare system
so that as people move from universal
credit into work they kept more of their
money that really helps low earners
we've cut tax on fuel so fuel duty cut
is the biggest fuel we know about this
chance i'm talking about more things i'm
talking about bigger tax and spending
interventions that you seem to be
resisting at the moment why no i'm just
explaining the things that are coming in
place already so in in july the national
insurance thresholds will be
raised to 12 and a half thousand pounds
that's one of the biggest personal tax
cuts we've seen for a decade 30 million
people are going to see something like
330 pounds tax reduction because of that
tax cut that's very significant and of
course i've said very clearly the
direction of travel on taxes is to
reduce them from where we are over time
of course i want to do that i've been
very clear about that